jump to the story from the Daily Caller
Obama once wrote to ex-girlfriend that
he repeatedly fantasizes about making
love to men biographer says from
President Obama once wrote that he
fantasized about having sexual relations
with other men biographer David Garrow
said in an interview published Wednesday
the former president expressed his
fantasies in a letter to a girlfriend at
the time Garrow told tablet magazine in
the interview that letter has been
redacted and is currently in possession
of Emory University according to Garrow
so they have this the ex-girlfriend
provided a copy of the letter but has
redacted one paragraph Garrow told
tablet who said she revealed the
paragraph was about homosexuality
sometime right about when Rising Star
came out Alex indirectly sold the
original sold those letters and they
ended up at Emory uh garro told tablet
while discussing this biography of Obama
Rising Star which touched on Obama
reportedly dreaming about homosexuality
so Emery put out a press release saying
we've gotten these rare Letters by
Barack Obama and no mention of this
paragraph that was too sensitive none of
the papers mentioned it Emery didn't
mention it so I emailed Harvey Claire
and said go to Emory archives he spent
his whole life at Emory but they won't
let him take pictures Carol said later
in the interview so Harvey has to sit
there with a pencil and copy out the
graph where Barack writes to Alex about
how he repeatedly fantasize about making
love to men Obama married his wife
former First Lady Michelle Obama in 92
Obama did not immediately respond to
daily caller's request for comment so
this is by his biographer saying that he
wrote this and I I can't imagine like I
don't know is this a thing like for a
guy to write his like private letter to
a girlfriend about wanting was Obama
trying to trick her for some reason or
is just it's just like he's admitting
this is what he's all about yeah is that
like is he trying to break up with her
by saying you know I'm actually secretly
in the guy well like maybe like that's I
mean like maybe he wasn't really meaning
it he was just like you know you're not
right for me because uh here you go yeah
but that's so awkward and embarrassing
to say I fantasize about having gay sex
if you're not actually fantasizing about
it well I I don't I don't know if it's
it could be embarrassing now that he's
like older and it was like this crude
youthful attempt at breaking up with
someone indirectly because you're too
scared to do it like a man see I feel
like it's not like bringing over I feel
like he's testing her to like see how
committed she is to him he's like okay
well I think about this and she's like
that's fine I'll stay with you no matter
what like that's really worse uh I also
I I I think they won't comment on this
but I would desperately love to see
Obamas come out and say but what's the
problem with this I mean I think we're
in the 21st you know what I mean like
because that's actually their their
easiest way out didn't Obama write that
whole uh letter about how he grew up
reading all of the books that uh like
Florida is Banning or whatever did you
say that something like I'll have to
find the tweet and I just saw uh
everybody quote tweeting it saying uh
yeah it looks like Obama just came out
as gay because all the books they're
banning are it was right before he
released his like summer reading list
now these books weren't released when
Brock was younger yeah like genderqueer
and stuff yeah and like how to bind some
of these books are so weird and they're
all available in the public libraries
well yeah but people were just like
making the joke saying that because it
was probably some stupid statement where
they were just saying oh they're banning
books because it's literally 1984. bogus
is trying to get the beef no you can't
have any beef carnivore snacks I think
they should actually ban all books just
no more books only the internet I'm big
on bisexuality right that's good you ban
all books and people are only allowed to
go on the internet but only X where Elon
Musk determines what you're allowed to
see and we have a guy's Creator because
you know I just I just don't like Mark
Zuckerberg critique Twitter I want Elon
Musk to be censoring Birds maybe because
you know you know shout out to Barack
for owning his bisexuality and that's
probably part of why he's so charismatic
if he's truly bisexual according to this
biography he is uh or anything
bisexuality the thing is you can
fantasize
David Bowie like they were just loose or
Mick is loose like and that's part of it
is his bicep he's like not afraid of sex
so he'll like touch anybody and that
makes him very easy to love for a man
and a woman
um so good for her but if he was
bisexual why didn't he come out sooner
right well also fantasizing doesn't make
you bisexual it's actually having sex
with men would have made him bisexual in
my opinion I don't think so I think it's
more of like a spiritual thing if you
want to do it that makes you bisexual
yeah Barack is attracted to men he is
you know it's like it's like if you're a
dude and you're a virgin but you're
attracted women you're not gay yes
you're not asexual because you've never
had sex like no you're talking to women
just like you're a virgin is it both
like because if you're straight but you
have a bunch of sex with guys
you're still straight ask him for a
friend why like if you'd be bi so you it
would make you gay to have sex with men
but it also makes you gay to think about
having sex with men what I'm saying is
let's say there's a guy there's a 20
year old guy and he's never been with a
woman but he's attracted to women he is
straight it doesn't matter if he did or
didn't yeah and there could be a guy
who's only attracted to guys he is gay
whether he did whether they do anything
or not and then you're saying there's a
guy who's only slept with guys but he's
still attracted to women he would just
be bi yeah so is Obama I guess the
question is like he's got how does he
respond to this does he say like you
know we never actually happened
he's like he just dreams every night or
something or what like if he comes out
too hard like no I'm not gay then like I
feel like the lgbtq lobby will be like
what well it's like not even a little
bit well did you see the lgbtq lobby is
mad at Bud Light for not doubling down
yeah they've lost all of their market
share and 400 million in sales Bud Light
Lost 400 million dollars in sales in the
last quarter or something like that and
the lobby doesn't care that's not market
share like market share is like their
stock drop no like they actually lost
that money in direct sales they're
laying people off they're shutting down
bottling plants the Distributors are
affected yeah they're they're saying
that they expect it not to recover well
because it'll always have that label as
the gay beer not that anything's wrong
with that it's great but that's who
their new faces though if Obama confirms
this letter then he shaves Bud Light wow
could you be could you imagine if he's
the next spokesman for Bud Light he's
like I'm gay and this is why because I
drink Bud Light do you think that a lot
of people are gay but they just don't
admit it
or bisexual and they don't admit it
these days I don't these days I don't
think so these days I think it's the
opposite I think people who aren't gay
are claiming they are yeah I actually
agree with Tim because then I think in
New York City they just made it where
you can put X as your gender in this
past year over 200 kids is put have put
well you get benefits yeah they're doing
it yeah for whatever the cloud uh let's
be real if you want a job let's say
you're you're 18 or whatever you're
trying to get a job nobody hire you
easiest easiest Tech you just put access
your gender then when you don't get
hired you you accuse them of of you know
discrimination and then you get in the
city pays you a hundred thousand dollars
because it's a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars for
um violating civil rights ordinances in
New York and it's 254 willful violation
so you've got this like exploit that
people are going to try and rip off
they're gonna they're gonna say but but
even beyond that you've got these
leftists who are claiming they're part
of the LGBT community because it gives
them brownie points you know like these
like 40 year old white leftists will be
like I'm actually non-binary and then
you know that way they can claim we when
they say LGBT and stuff like that yeah
someone's like being transgender these
days is like what being goth was in the
90s it was like the trendy edgy thing to
do which means that eventually it's not
right well even the term lgbtq is kind
of
um hypocritical because if you say
lesbian gay bisexual yeah the b means
there's two genders
yes yeah when are they going to replace
that with this LG
lgp oh pansexual they already did that's
why it's like two lbtq no it's like LGBT
something like that but they'll drop the
B is what I'm saying that's my favorite
thing in Canada where they had the
banner of lgbtqia plus they had it all
and just Trudeau couldn't say it yeah go
nailed it
and they had to correct him and they
like he like sighed and then said it and
it was just like so funny every every
pride month that's what I tweeted out so
you have like a way to commemorate the
month yes I do
absolutely do you think there were other
presidents who were gay like we just
don't know sure who was the one who
never got married that was like the
rumor that he was gay
never got married I'm gonna look it up
there was one that was always single he
was never married
maybe that sounds kind of gay poking I
know Paul James sounds like wait no
lifelong bachelor yeah Buchanan wow I
don't
I don't saying people making something
he was the pre-civil war president a man
of a certain age who never got married I
mean it raises questions I know
especially back then too I mean yeah if
you can was like was like second worst
president we've ever had right the
concept of a confirmed Bachelor like
that was an illusion to like we think
that oh you think about the women that
threw themselves at him like he was the
president of the United States that he
couldn't get married I'm sorry but like
where was where was the ancient uh
Bachelor show to like make this happen
Buchanan was engaged to Ann Coleman
daughter of a wealthy Pennsylvania
family but they broke up the engagement
for an undisclosed reason and then
Coleman died shortly after oh wow
the Buchanan body count okay
and he's really good looking right yeah
what he looks like Beethoven there's one
president that everyone is like no he is
the understate uh JFK no hold on I'm
gonna look he definitely wasn't gay
is this attractive to you yeah you can
no that's not who I was thinking of it's
just like Sam Smith yeah he does that's
Sam Smith when you when you Googled that
President Buchanan is the first one that
I'm telling you this is all for real
because he was never married and I'm
sorry there are other politicians that
this comes up about too the the idea I
mean it's like a joke that I mean uh uh
Yellowstone makes this joke that like
the son who wants to run for office
they're like yeah but you have to get
married because otherwise it starts to
look weird like there's an expectation
that hopefully by a certain point of
life you have this you know partner uh
and I think James Buchanan has always
been a mystery for history you think he
was like and it's not gonna work because
I'm gay and she's like that I'm leaving
you and he's like I shouldn't have told
her that what was I thinking I mean
there's no evidence as far as I know I'm
just saying the oh the biggest thing
that people question is the fact that he
never got married oh look at this
Stephen says he was never married and
was the only US president to remain a
lifelong bachelor leading some
historians and authors to question his
sexual orientation
respiratory failure in 1868 and was
buried in Lancaster Pennsylvania uh
historians will question your sexuality
no matter what at this point because
they would love to weave as many uh gay
icons into the past as possible I heard
that yeah that's crazy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time